ajuste el coeficiente principal y las
coordenadas del vértice para hacer
coincidir la parábola azul con la
naranja ahora ya hemos visto cómo hacer
para desplazar estas parábolas si
restamos algo al aire la parábola es
desplazada hacia arriba a esta cantidad
y ya hemos hablado de esto antes en el
vídeo de desplazamiento y ajuste de
parábolas pero hay que realmente verlo
en la práctica porque esto nos va a
permitir experimentar
entonces veremos que si incrementamos
este número la parábola se desplaza
hacia abajo mientras que si lo
disminuimos se desplaza hacia arriba
pero de hecho debemos desplazarla hacia
abajo para este ejemplo ahora por lo
menos el valor de y de los vértices
parece igual y similarmente cuando
desplazamos lo que sea que estemos
elevando al cuadrado cada vez si
desplazamos si restamos un valor aquí se
mueve a la derecha mientras que si
sumamos valores se desplazan a la
izquierda así que vamos a verificar esto
entonces si restamos un valor aquí se
desplaza hacia la derecha y si sumamos
un valor aquí se desplaza hacia la
izquierda ahora justo así parece que
logramos que ambos vértices coincidan
este vértice de aquí está en el punto
donde x es igual a menos 4 y que es
igual a menos 3 y no es pura
coincidencia x igual a menos 4 hace que
esto sea 0 y de igual a menos 3 hace que
esto sea 0
pero estas dos parábolas aún no están
emparejadas esta parábola amarilla
parece crecer más rápido así que el
coeficiente principal justo aquí parece
ser muy bajo para el azul así que
aumentemos lo y aquí estamos mejor con
un 2 crece más rápido crece
suficientemente rápido pero con un 3
crece demasiado rápido si hacemos 0 este
valor se vuelve una línea horizontal y
después se vuelve negativa así que
vayamos de regreso al 2 positivo y hemos
terminado